il se veut confiant
le président céline ce qui a rendu lundi
le questionnaire d'adhésion de son pays
à l'union européenne une première étape
pour que l'ukraine obtiennent
officiellement le statut de candidat
notre pays vient de franchir une des
étapes pour entrer dans l'union
européenne c'est ce à quoi aspire notre
peuple ce pourquoi nous nous battons
à l'union européenne désormais de
trancher sur le sort de l'ukraine le
processus pour devenir candidat peut
prendre plus d'un an mais le président
ukrainien tablent sur une candidature
officielle dès le mois de juin prochain
lors de sa visite à kiev il ya dix jours
ursula von der leyen lui avait promis
une procédure accélérée
nous sommes à vos côtés vous qui rêvez
d'europe mon cher vaut le tenir mon
message aujourd'hui est très claire
l'ukraine appartient à la famille
européenne
même si elle obtient le statut de
candidat l'ukraine devra faire face à de
nombreux obstacles juridiques
l'alignement de sa législation avec
celle de l'europe peut prendre des
années et certains pays comme la france
ne veulent pas précipiter les choses
de son côté la russie voit d'un mauvais
oeil l'adhésion de l'ukraine au bloc
européen mais le président hélène ce qui
a fait un pas de côté il propose
d'abandonner la candidature de son pays
à l'otan l'une des principales
revendications du kremlin